good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 39 73 object
class safe special containment
procedures the following paragraph was
stricken from the document but I figured
I'd include it anyway
SCP 39 73 is to be kept in a locked box
and placed inside a standard anomalous
item Locker in the site 16 storage room
testing is approved for staff level 2
and higher staff who wish to test SCP 39
73 must make an entry in a logbook
located in the site 16 storage room this
concludes the stricken portion of the
containment procedures following
interview 39 73 1 and dr. harpies
request SCP 39 73's containment
procedures are to be changed SCP 39 73 s
to be kept in a locked 30 centimeter
cubed acrylic glass box insight 16s
anomalous item research lab 104 the
scenery inside of the glass box should
be changed once a month as an incentive
for SCP 39 73 to continue to comply with
interviews the scenery may be changed by
adding more miniatures plastic foliage
sand or plastic rocks these have been
provided by dr. harpy and can be found
in a label box in the site 16 break room
staff who wish to test or interview SCP
39 73 must have a security clearance of
level 2 or higher and received
permission from dr. harpy first
description SCP 39 73 is a standard
miniature from the tabletop wargame
Warhammer 40,000 the object is
physically unremarkable being composed
of plastic and reaching a height of
about three point three centimeters SCP
39 73 is covered in layers of bran model
paint
the objects only apparent anomalous
property is an influence over the
outcome of dice rolls within a 50
centimeter radius caused by unknown
means when it was originally contained
all dice rolled within a 50 centimeter
radius of SCP 39 73 always landed with
the lowest side facing up due to this
SCP 39 73 was originally classified as
an anomalous item and denied full SCP
classification for a total of months SCP
39 73 was kept in storage in one of
sight 16s anomalous item lockers during
one of the site 16s routine anomalous
item checks incident 39 73 FC occurred
see below for details incident 39 73 FC
the following is an excerpt from the log
of dr. harpy at the time dr. harpy was
performing routine anomaly checks on
multiple items from site 16s anomalous
items Department item description a
tabletop wargame miniature that
influenced dice rolled within a 50
centimeter radius to land with lowest
side facing up date of recovery
september 2nd location of recovery
current status a standard anomalous item
locker insight 16 testing materials 1
u.s. corner 1 four-sided die 1 six-sided
9 1 8 sided die 10 12 and 20 sided die
test one procedure 1 u.s. quarter is
flipped with an item's area-of-effect
results the quarter lands vertically on
its side test repeated 5 times with the
same results for brevity tests 2 through
to 6 have been excluded procedure
included rolling each die multiple times
and each test resulted in the die
landing with the one side facing up
test seven procedure an impromptu test
after accidentally knocking multiple
dice into the objects area of effect a
total of six dice were rolled in the 50
centimeter area results dice landed in a
pattern that resembled a smiley face
with the six and four sided dice making
two eyes and the rest forming its mouth
test repeated a total of seven times
with the dice landing in the exact same
formation each time requesting further
research into the anomalous properties
of this object experiment log 39 73 won
for brevity the following excerpts are
some of the more important findings from
experiments with SCP 39 73 test one
procedure asked for dyed to land on the
two side results dye landed on the two
side after several tests to confirm that
the results were an anomalous effect and
not merely a coincidence
dr. harpy suggested asking SCP
thirty-nine 73 if it was listening or
could understand them as it was able to
give them the numbers that they asked
for test 14 procedure asked if SCP
thirty-nine 73 could understand what the
doctors were saying with that to side
for yes and the three side for no
results the dye landed with the two
sides facing up analysis the possibility
of sapience in SCP 39 73 is considered
test 15
procedure asked of SCP 39 73 was aware
of what was going on around it results
the dye landed with the two side facing
up test 16 procedure asked if SCP 39 73
had thoughts results the dye landed with
the two side facing up note in the
months that SCP 39 73 has been in
foundation custody it has been kept in a
box in a locked anomalous item
containment locker now we are faced with
the possibility of sapiens
dr. harpy through testing it was
revealed that SCP 39 73 exhibits signs
of sapiens a communication system has
been established with SCP 39 73 the
object must be placed on a surface that
has a radius less than 50 centimeters
the interviewer can then roll a 20-sided
and six-sided die SCP 39 73 will make
the dice show a number that lines up
with the letter of the alphabet
if the letter is on a spot in the
alphabet lower than 20 SCP 39 73 will
make the six-sided die fall off the
table all dice falling off the table
indicates a period interview 39 73 1
interviewed SCP 39 73 interviewer dr.
harpy forward dr. harpy performed the
interview with the Afra mentioned
dice-based communication system and for
entertainment value SCP 39 73 has been
given a voice by my AI acid playing log
now what's the first thing that you can
remember is CP 39 73 where is commander
commander can you elaborate commander
took me in squadron pulled us together
made us we are today
others there are more like you others
but not like me look the same but no
brains still nice to be around what's
the last thing that you can remember
before being put into our custody
commander was upset not sure why was
helping commander win big battle giving
highest roles people seemed mad at
commander call them cheater I thought I
did something wrong
decided to give lowest instead of
highest from then on too late
commander left us in a drop pod
if they see you've done well as CB 39 73
any closing remarks thank you for
listening
sergeant end log note following
interview 39 73 1
I am formally requesting a change in the
containment procedures for SCP 39 73
I suggest moving the object to a glass
box in an anomalous item research lab so
it can see people more often as a reward
for being compliant during interviews
dr. harvey addendum SCP 39 73 was
discovered at a war game tournament in
the city a foundation agent agent who
was attending that tournament on their
personal time and heard rumors of a
competitor who had been accused of
cheating at multiple tournaments left
all his figures behind in a box after
getting banned for cheating at the
tournament agents took the box home to
try to find out how the cheating had
occurred shortly after the anomalous
property was discovered several items
were discovered in the box that SCP
thirty-nine 73 was founded including
several more Space Marine miniatures
several types of dice and photographs of
miniatures posed together SCP 39 73 is
possibly in one of them hmm I don't know
about owing you but an item that can
influence chance I don't know seems to
me like we're just scratching the
surface of what this thing can do if it
can influence chance where does it end
anyway I'm thinking too much they don't
like it when I think thank you for
listening if indeed you still are and
you were all dismissed good
I would like to give a special thank you
to the Morrigan GM's
Saba orbiter soul it's not a spoon
Darius Tom
Justin day NJ Vujic Cory Barker Longinus
the commissar Chloe Harlan and Samurai
corgis if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volcan
thank you
you